evaluate the following expression when x
is equal to seven and they give us
negative three x minus six so wherever
we see the x that is now going to be
equal to seven so this is the same thing
as negative 3
times
negative 3 times 7
negative 3 times 7
minus 6. and negative 3 times 7 this
part right over here is negative 21
and then we're going to subtract 6 from
that negative 21 minus 6 is equal to
negative
27.
next one evaluate the following
expressions when x is equal to
8
negative 10 x minus 9. so this is going
to be when x is equal to 8 is going to
be negative 10
times 8
times 8. before where we saw an x we now
have an 8
minus 9
minus 9 and this is going to be equal to
negative 10 times 8 is negative 80 and
then we want to subtract 9 from that so
negative 80 minus 9 that is negative 89.
and then one more
evaluate the following expression it
really should be expression there's only
one expression right over here
expression expression when x is equal to
10
x is equal to 10 so it's 8 times x plus
ten x is ten
so it's eight times ten which is eighty
plus ten which is ninety so this is
eighty
eighty
plus ten which is equal to ninety and
we're done